Bryan Cranston who as you know had to
recreate a famous movie character for
the Broadway version of network after
news anchor Howard Beale has an on-air
breakdown his bosses exploited big time
to get better TV ratings and don't stop
you first you've got to get mad when
you're mad enough then we'll figure out
what to do
Bryan Cranston is nominated for a Tony
Award for the role the congratulations
it's interesting that you just said to
us I've never seen that because that's
such a powerful scene on the play and a
very powerful scene in the movie and I
don't know how you get up the anger and
the emotion to do that night after night
after night who help us understand you
know it's it's part of the actors
toolkit to be able to go inward and to
your own personal experiences and pull
out whatever you need at any given time
rage jealousy love joy anger is an
emotion though Bryan that makes people
very uncomfortable also so necessary
well I think I especially now it's
usually shunned in our society I see
someone who's angry we don't want to be
anywhere around you but there's a lot of
anxiety in our social circles now and in
our country a lot of bitterness and
divisive nough sanger is a way to you
know to really thrive and release that
pressure that's one of the most famous
speeches in the history of film Peter
Finch one had me a word for that role so
I mean when you're when you're taking on
something like that how do you how do
you approach it well every time you take
on a character for an actor it's outside
of you and the more I work the more I do
research the more I get into the head of
this man the more he's invited in and at
some point you just trust that the
character
lack a better term osmosis just and just
sinks into you
yeah and then you own him then you then
you operate from from that point of view
the original film that were famous
critique of television news in the 70s
yeah
fast forward to today what's the
relevancy of the message now well I
think the adaptation well when I was a
kid growing up and and watching Walter
Cronkite I always believed that what I
was listening to was was just pure news
yeah and I believe it still was but
there were decisions being made by
producers back then as there are now you
have 25 stories we can only get to 12
who makes that decision of what you're
not going to say who decides what
decides what's news and what's the more
important news and you hope that it's
altruistic in that decision making but
sometimes an ideology does say well I
believe this is true so this is what
we're going to say do you look at the
news differently after doing this role I
think I think you could look at it with
a little bit of skepticism and I think
it's prudish you know actually to say
that and I I think the the point of
network is not to to put yourself in any
kind of tribalistic ideological camp yes
to allow yourself to open up to to
receive different ideas from all
different sources and make up your own
mind of what you mentioned this at one
point you actually go out into the
audience and actually like sit on up in
between seats with a couple people I
thought you just did that last night I
didn't know that was something that you
did every night every night cuz it's got
to be a different experience that's a
different every night last night the
lady said I've always wanted to meet you
you've had people have had a sandwich
when you got out there right yeah
sometimes they're there in the middle of
they have the takeout bag and I I open
it up I'll take a bite of something I
have free rein to do whatever Howard
Beale wants to do at that moment yeah
because it's it's important for that
moment yeah
or the audience to see that he is his
promulgating the idea of letting go he
has gone over to the other side he says
don't struggle anymore don't fight
against the machine yeah let go the
staging - Brian is so well done really
creative yeah the technology that's
incorporated the way they do the control
room of the news or a lot of it's
actually televised yes in the room yeah
it's really appropriate to have all the
multimedia that you see in the show
because it is television now there was
one thing we were talking about in the
green room which is what's the problem
with media today is it television still
as Network has as its thesis or is it
now social media well I I think I don't
think that that today's television media
can be absorbed over the responsibility
of being able to to put forth honest
good journalism everyone is under
pressure of ratings yeah you know it
ratings and making money and sometimes
you'll see programs that is all about
promoting that night's shows and things
it's like well is this news or are we
just a promotional vehicle for something
else speaking of making money we've got
it we've got to make some Bryan Cranston
thank you very much watch Network
congratulations on the Tony nomination
that work is on Broadway right now